you know you really captured his Essence
maybe his face could use a little more
detail though
take a photograph
I'm Adam
Chloe
[Music]
oh my God
this might be the nicest thing anyone's
ever done for me
you have 62 viewers and 300 total
[Music]
they don't have love in their culture
they find romantic stuff super exotic
and interesting
they watch you go on dates
family dinner is one of our most
cherished human rituals do you have to
do this right now Chloe you're not
supposed to talk about the broadcast on
the broadcast
and in space hey would you keep that
out of my line of sight why don't
you keep your out of our line of
sight you didn't invent courtship
broadcast
it has recently become obvious you are
deceiving your viewers what deceiving
the title of your broadcast is Adam and
Chloe in love and yet you are not in
love
I want you to repay all funds you have
received wait we've already spent
everything we made just to live
and your family
sex Generations
all right
do you want me to cut that for you
[Music]
where is the nearest restaurant
no part of my body can make that noise
well it certainly won't if you don't try
[Music]
romantic love is the most poetic of all
human love mods it should never be faked
I'm just like any other person I want to
grow up and fall in love and be swept
off my feet
we've lost a lot since you guys came
here
but we've overcome a lot too
foreign
[Music]